يبدو أنه من المحتمل أن تكون إيطاليا قد
تجاوزت الأسوأ عندما يتعلق
الأمر بفيروس كورونا مساء الثلاثاء ، حيث
ذكرت وكالة الحماية المدنية الإيطالية
أن عدد الحالات الجديدة يستمر
في النمو ، وكما قال معدل أقل من أي وقت مضى ،
فإن عدد الأشخاص الذين
يتم قبولهم  إلى وحدات العناية المركزة
لفيروس كورونا هو ثلث ما
كان عليه قبل خمسة أيام ،
كما أن عدد المرضى الذين يدخلون
المستشفى هو ثلث ما كان عليه قبل
خمسة أيام ، ومع ذلك استمر الأشخاص في
الخطوط الأمامية لهذا الصراع
ضد الفيروس في الدفع
لقد توفي 66 طبيبًا إيطاليًا حتى الآن بسبب
فيروس كورونا ، وقد ثبت أن ما يقرب من 9000 طبيبًا إيطاليًا
إيجابيًا ،
وتواصل الحكومة الإيطالية مناقشة إمكانية
تمديد الإغلاق الحالي الذي من
المفترض أن ينتهي في الثالث من
أبريل ، هناك حديث عن  تمديده
ربما إلى 12 أبريل وربما
تخفيفه في بعض أجزاء البلاد
والحفاظ عليه في مناطق أخرى أنا بن
ويدمان سي إن إن  التقارير من روما